thank you to ancestry for supporting pbs
[Music]
phillip come here look what a huge tree
fell on our neighbor's car last night in
the storm
oh that's awful uh it's amazing
we're going to cabo baby what are you
talking about
well i had a hunch that something
horrible was gonna happen to them
so i went and bought a massive insurance
policy on their car
make it rain baby um is that legal
oh you're such a boy scout now if i can
get something
bad to happen to their cat we can
upgrade to first class
whenever you purchase an investment
you're hoping that it will go
up in value by buying a company stock
you win if they win
we're all in this together right well
not always
since the very beginning of stock
investing people have found a way to
profit when companies
struggle or fail the first instance was
in 1609 when a dutch businessman named
isaac lemaire
speculated that the dutch east india
company stock was due for a big drop
and he wanted to make some money if he
was right in amsterdam at the time there
was already a system in place to make
money if
prices of grain fell and that gave him
an idea
lemaire headed to the bridge in town
where stocks were traded by an elaborate
hand slapping system no joke and found
somebody to take his bet
the process of speculating on the future
fall of a company's stock is called
short selling or shorting
for short to most people the process can
seem confusing and complex and it can
create
downward pressure on a company or asset
potentially
ensuring it's doom it's for these
reasons that society tends to dislike
and distrust short sellers
in 1772 a short selling scheme
precipitated a near total collapse of
every bank in scotland many americans
blamed short sellers for the great crash
of 1929 that led to the great depression
and as recently as this year the short
selling of
gamestop and amc stock created such a
fervor
that it caught the attention of treasury
secretary yellen as a possible threat to
the stability of markets
but how does this even work how do you
bet that a stock will fall
essentially the way to do it is to
borrow the stock from a brokerage firm
and then
immediately sell it to someone else this
is where the term
short came from you are selling
something you don't have or are
short of when the price of the stock
falls as you expect
you buy back at the lower cost and
return it to the brokerage firm keeping
the difference
as profit sounds simple enough but is
this the kind of investment that the
average person should attempt to really
understand the promise and
perils of short selling i think we need
to
run the numbers
works in the floral industry and
recently observed a frenzy for tulip
bulbs
it's gotten downright crazy lately with
people trading wedding bands and even
used cars for a single bulb but yannick
knows a bubble when he sees one so he
hatches a plan
to short sell the stock of the biggest
tulip company in the world
tulips international which just hit an
all-time high of 200
per share his first step is to choose a
brokerage firm and open a special type
of account
known as a margin account this will
allow him to borrow shares directly from
the brokerage company
he wants to short sell 10 shares of
tulips international
so he borrows them from the brokerage at
the current price of 200
per share in order to lend him these
shares his brokerage wants him to put
some skin in the game and requires him
to deposit
25 of the loan amount in his margin
account
that five hundred dollars is his only
personal capital contribution at this
point
the firm loans yannick two thousand
dollars worth of tli stock
at one percent margin interest and he
instantly turns around and sells
all ten shares to mila he puts mila's
two thousand dollars into his margin
account and now sits back to watch the
tulip bubble burst
let's just say that yannick's spidey
sense is proven
right over the next 30 days the stock
drops and drops losing half of its value
he buys the 10 stocks back from poormina
for just a hundred dollars a share
and returns them to the brokerage firm
pocketing the difference
taking out one dollar and sixty-six
cents in interest for the loan and
ten dollars in trading fees yannick
posted a gain
of 988 dollars and 34 cents
that's a 197 profit
on his original contribution of just
five hundred dollars
sounds like a good gamble but the real
risk in short selling
isn't the upfront cost what if yanick
turned out to be wrong
what if the share price didn't fall but
continued its climb
eventually reaching three hundred
dollars per share
this is bad news because remember he
doesn't owe the brokerage two thousand
dollars he owes them ten shares of
tulips international and he'll have to
get them back no matter how much it
costs him
maybe he thinks the price will still
fall and he can wait it out
but the brokerage firm won't allow his
debt to deposit ratio to get too high
so he'll have to keep depositing money
into his margin account as the price of
the stock gets higher
at this point yannick admits he is no
nostradamus he decides to cut his losses
buy back the ten shares for three
thousand dollars and return them to the
brokerage company
this saddles him with a realized loss of
a
thousand dollars on the sale alone and
once you include the trading fees and
interest he had to pay
he's looking at a 202
loss which is obviously more than his
starting amount of 500.
this is why short selling is big time
risky business
typically when you invest you can only
lose up to the value of the amount you
purchased
100 loss is the worst case scenario
but with shorting you can lose more than
your starting amount as porionic found
out
in fact since the gains on the
investment are
technically unlimited short selling
creates the possibility
for infinite losses yikes
nevertheless short selling is and always
has been a
standard function of investment markets
everyday investors like you
and me all the way to wall street hedge
funds can short nearly any type of
investment
hoping that the price drops but
sometimes
investors aren't content to just hope
they want to
make it drop remember our friend isaac
lemaire
after he shorted the world's first stock
in the 1600s he went around town
spreading rumors and lies about the
company
did you hear about the dutch east india
ship that sank off the coast
or how leaky sea water is going to ruin
the taste of pepper
this would be considered unethical today
but in a modern version when hedge funds
team up
and heavily shored a company it can
shake investor confidence
the company goes into an artificially
accelerated death spiral
with shorted investors gleefully
hovering like vultures
ready to swoop in and claim victory well
at least that's how it usually works
sometimes the little guys decide to
fight back
here to explain is cfa investment
analyst richard coffin from the plain
bagel
in january of 2021 a group of investors
online discovered
that gamestop a struggling video game
retailer
was being excessively short sold by
hedge funds
but while a sizable short interest is
usually a bad omen
these investors use this information to
send the stock skyrocketing
by triggering what's known as a short
squeeze
a short squeeze occurs when a rising
stock price prompts a
rush for the exit by short sellers
because these investors are
losing money some may decide or indeed
be
forced to cut their losses and buy back
the stock to close their position
but by abandoning the short sale ship
these investors
end up sinking it faster for those left
behind
their buy orders can push the price
higher still
prompting other investors to jump ship
and buy the stock back themselves
this positive feedback loop can send a
stock surging
over a very short period of time and the
larger the short interest to begin with
the more returns can be squeezed out of
the short sellers
after buying gamestop shares to get the
ball rolling themselves
our online investors prompted quite the
surge in the stock
with gamestop's share price jumping over
seventeen hundred percent
in january alone needless to say it was
quite the rude awakening for those who
thought gamestop's decline
was a sure bet the long and the short of
it is
yes you can make real money when an
investment falls in value
but it's speculative and exposes you to
the possibility of
unlimited losses so before you dip your
toe into the world of short selling
make sure you understand the risks are
highly familiar with investing tools
and aren't gambling with money you can't
afford to lose and then some
and that's our two cents thank you to
ancestry for supporting pbs
was that your great-grandmother keeping
the family together
was that your great-grandfather paving
the way for change
did they brave mother nature and walk
away stronger
did they face the unknown with resolve
and triumph
there is strength in every family story
ancestry can help you learn about yours
visit ancestry.com for more information
thanks to our patrons for keeping two
cents financially healthy
click the link in the description to
become a two cents patron
the stock market doesn't have to feel
like a high stakes casino
check out our video how risky is the
stock market
you